pick you wait I just played your floors
yeah they're not clean well they're
clean now
I'm food oh I can't believe it I just on
that do not not the dog
forget the dog house wickets no no is
this a good idea bad idea
great okay all right all right wait I'm
gonna go I'm gonna follow you this is a
good song though yeah good you got this
[__] where you go yeah all right oh my
gosh I can't let this is happening right
now
oh my god yeah I'm dying
oh my god aah
that's gonna leave a walker
my god [__] my hip bone no baby
my life is like it's not bad
oh no you know I have an item urgency
numbers for the better
oh are you okay Oh chip the bone I'm
just not filming now somebody sit down
we're not only to said now imma walk
this one off oh I guess tears in my eyes
right now you're good
we're fine I'm laughing cause I don't
know what else to do oh my gosh